like any girl that dates me
is i think lucky because i'm i'll tell
you why
because i don't think you should tell us
why i think you should just leave it at
that any girl that dates you is lucky no
but go ahead tell us why because i'm
extreme like i'm extremely supportive
and i also she's a king maker
what does that mean what she's a king
maker i don't know what that means i'm
gonna explain it to you okay
before i matter
yeah
i was on the verge of suicide
oh my career
was in the [ __ ] box
it was in the [ __ ] box highway
and when she met me she looked at my
life
and she kind of figured out how do we
get this guy because i love this guy
back on top
right and so she made
a plan
she would force me to do things that i
didn't want to do
but in retrospect it helped
with me getting my career back
i'll give you an example
i
got to the point where i refused to do
auditions
because i never got them and i and and
the as the rejection was hard yeah as
the years went on
they became almost traumatic for me
because i would be in a room and i would
get in my own head and just already i
was defeated like i'm not gonna get this
so it would affect the performance it
got to the point where it's like every
time it was like this big traumatic
thing so i said i'm done i'm not going
in so i didn't go in for years
and then they stopped coming when you
stopped saying no they stopped coming
right so what my girlfriend said was
that's gonna change i go i'm not gonna
get it she goes
i'm gonna break up with you if you don't
change that
right so
one day what i used to do is i used to
my agent would go you have an audition
tomorrow too at nbc let's say right i go
okay i wouldn't read it because knowing
that the next day i'd find some excuse
not to go
so one morning i had this nbc audition
for this pilot
and
i slept till 1 30 was at 2 o'clock she
wakes me up she goes all right let's go
let's get in the car
and i go
i didn't read it
she goes i don't care
you're doing it
i'm not i'm going to look like a fool
i don't give a [ __ ] are you a [ __ ]
yes
i'm a big [ __ ] i don't care i'll break
up with you get in the [ __ ] car
so we drive down there
right and it's like you know it's one of
those things where i i was at a point
where i didn't get a lot drive in right
so i had to park outside of this lot go
in get the id then go in right right and
i wouldn't go in and she grabbed my hair
i'm not kidding she got out of the car
and grabbed my hair and pulled me out
get in there right can you imagine being
outside of nbc all right and so i have
this crumple up script
and i'm being no i don't want it
it was a [ __ ] thing to do right
i'm gonna get to it aren't we oh no no
so we i get in
and it's one of those auditions where
everyone in the lobby i know
like every actor they're all my friends
right so
and i'm making announcements i didn't
read it right
so then i waited like an hour and then
finally they go bobby lee
and i go i i go i'm just gonna read it
like this so i go in
i'm bobby lee
and i just kind of just i just start
reading it he dropped a mic for those
that are just listening that he's
standing up he's performing yeah i'm
performing it so i'm like i just gotta
i'm just saying the lines
right and now there's eight people in
the room right and they're all like
what the [ __ ] is this
and then
i kind of crumbled up the thing in my
hand yeah i threw in the trash right
there like a slam dunk
then they laughed
i left it
i left the room
and i'm like kind of in the verge of
tears i was i look like fool
i got it
no i got the part what was it
it was a um
there was a movie called problem child
yeah and they were trying to make it
into a tv show because nbc had the
rights to it or whatever yeah and i got
the second lead in it
[ __ ] amazing i got in the car and i
go i told you
she's like i just want you to go in and
face your fears two days later they go
we want you to test
right but i'll tell you why
because somebody in the room was a huge
fan of mine right and when i left
everyone was like [ __ ] that guy and she
went trust me
that's the guy
and they go
he didn't know his line trust me i know
he was the showrunner that's the guy
that's the guy we need so that monday i
tested
i got it i needed to put we didn't get
picked up but it showed me it showed me
you have to try
i always say you have to say you have to
say yes
[Music]
you